then let's live and we're live what's
going on guys this is Rob and Benny's
not here as you can tell it is me Sal
and Faust so we're just speculating
about post secret war stuff because a
big question is what's gonna happen like
once all the comics are over once all
the stories are over and all we have is
battle world what stories are gonna come
to an end so I'm actually really excited
to have to jump into this because
there's all kinds of stuff that like I
really really wanted to get into um we
were talking before the podcast started
and we were talking about you're talking
about spider-man about the new
spider-man film and bit Earth's now you
were saying something about Joker saw
this saying that it was gonna be Peter
Parker it's gonna be Peter Parker
apparently they have a quote from Joe
Quesada saying essentially they were
asking him about like what we're gonna
see like who they're thinking they were
trying to elicit some kind of quote like
you know who like more or less they were
looking for like casting decisions or
maybe some kind of inkling as to what
movie he might be up here in and they
asked and casada basically said as long
as we get he's like the essential thing
is to get Peter Parker right and once
Peter Parker is done correctly
spider-man falls right into place and
we're like I guess you're doing Peter
Parker then okay all you Miles Morales
fans can shut up now like shut up Miles
Morales fans I just mean like too bad
it's not gonna be him it's gonna be
Peter Parker was I really knew anyone
there that was like do Matty Franklin
she pretended to be spider-man and no
one would be expecting it it's true I
mean like Matty Franklin they're not
gonna she's still dead I think they
forgot about her cuz she could have been
in spite of us but she wasn't no well
they forgot about her after it did you
see did you ever read alias Brent Bendis
is a crime war vehicle for Jessica Jones
that was an amazing series amazing
series also introduced not introduced
but included Maddy Franklin she was like
this drug dealers like tent-like town
bicycle it was horrible and she was just
hooked on drugs and it was
disaster and then grim hunt happened and
they just murdered her like groans crap
it's killed her so that's the end that
was the end of Maddie Franklin for now
unless your name's Kane you know you're
not you're not usually coming back from
from death if you're a spider care even
poor Ben Riley can't escape death yeah
the big one but when I eventually start
writing to Marvel and they say to me who
do you want to write I'll be like magic
Franklin right and nobody ever cared oh
we did didn't we be like that you're
gonna have to like prove that they did
have a character named Maddie Franklin
like like this whole calling series she
changed costume every issue yeah you
should read it shows it's fun I think
Howard Mac you wrote some of that but um
but yeah so it looks like it's gonna be
Peter Parker and I don't know like see
here I don't know how I feel about that
because it's it's it's time for Peter
Parker to take a back seat in the films
he's like we need some miles more Ellis
for them to stick to a franchise like I
don't know III fur for me I was actually
most excited about the prospect of
spider-man being in the Avengers as ammo
as I'm sure many other people were after
seeing Andrew Garfield be spider-man I
think I was content back in pre I guess
like we need to as comic book-like movie
fans and his comic book fans we need to
like classify comic book movies is like
p IM pre Iron Man and post Iron Man
because pre Iron Man the spider-man
franchise was kind of fun but post Iron
Man spider-man franchise looks like
garbage because oh my god you know just
and of course having it be directed by
Sam Raimi really doesn't help because
you have like fist cam and you have like
just every Liberty taken by a guy who
loves goofy can't be nonsense yeah but
uh but for most of us like I I don't
know I loved Andrew Garfield spider-man
and an amazing spider-man we finally at
least got the costume right so I was
really excited to see that but now that
now that we're looking at like a sixteen
year old spider-man who was like deeply
seated in high school who could be
anyone probably from the divergent movie
series I'm kind of like okay well like
the thing was spider-man for me is I
don't want to see a Hollywood looking
Peter Parker I want to see it like an
unattractive dude I want to just look at
him and go oh dear maybe better luck in
the next life
he's never been unattractive the Peter
Parker has never been nebbish looking
except like like one panel in ultimate
spider-man I'm not saying I want like a
troll to play him another thing to show
me I'm just worried too [ __ ] pretty
to play Peter Parker he's not supposed
to be drop pants gorgeous slippery when
wet that's not supposed to be Peter Park
he's just supposed to be yeah we
supposed to be average like so if he
loses his mask and then he runs into a
crowd you'll lose him yeah I mean yeah
well imagine like a him like a Steve
Buscemi like Steve Buscemi like a crazy
eyes yeah like Steve Buscemi really
unattractive dude that's what we need we
need to have Steve Buscemi playing
spider-man and everybody need to be
sitting in a diner and then ask him like
why don't you tip and needs to go on
like a rant about how he doesn't tip
yeah he's saving all of his money for
animes like medical bills no yeah but
anyway with with respect to our
speculation market the the spider-man
movie looks like it's gonna be same as
usual
no no surprises as far as the character
is concerned yeah
which is fine I I don't want to see
miles Percy miles well I think Miles
Morales has a great character history
like like the entire basis behind Miles
Morales and he's like a kid that grew up
in the hood and his uncle was like a
criminal that reformed himself you know
what's so unlike I think that's really
kind of a cool concept well he kind of
reformed like he didn't really but
unless I think it'd be kind of a really
cool concept for his character like I
think it'd be really cool to bring in
that version of miles where I think
Foster's right like more so than just
like physical attractiveness like like
no one can identify with Peter Parker in
the films he's just like oh hey I'm just
a kid they kind of grew up in
and I'm kind of picked on a school a
little bit but not really and like
there's nothing about that character
where people are like I've lived that
same kind of life right there just like
like that guy had a same kind of life
you see in like a like a teenage movie
right you know I mean well it's hard to
tell
spider-man like that like the Peter
Parker spider-man today because it's a
different it's a totally different world
like if you take it if you take the 60s
version which has been the version until
like you know the last 20 years you have
a character who like has always been
described as like a loner and outsider a
kid who was always picked on really
overly intelligent for his age he's
bullied often and he's prone to like
having violent thoughts you ever read
like the old Stan Lee did coke look like
he is really like though like I think
one of the first things he ever thinks
an amazing fantasy 15 is like I'll show
them and in 1964 you're kind of like
yeah I hope you do but in like post to
post 1999 you're like oh that does not
sound was gonna shoot up a school
exactly and it's so like you know get
that kid some counseling you put him in
a social program and you maybe get him
classified like Peter Parker as he was
all has he has always been is a very
different animal and it's hard to tell
that kind of version of him honestly
which is kind of I think why people like
Miles Morales so much because he's
Origen he gets to the same place as a
person and as spider-man with by taking
a totally different road
we don't make him like a social outcast
we don't make him a downtrodden youth
you know tormented by the by his betters
you know we have just a kid who is poor
and he is you know the victim of
circumstance and through it all and
despite his his his obstacles he
succeeds and that's that's the basis of
spider-man so like I like the Miles
Morales character I was kind of like I'm
like I don't know I would have felt
really gypped
if I am seen Miles Morales spider-man in
the Avengers movies I would be like
really like we waited this long to
finally get Peter Parker spider-man in
these friggin Marvel movies and it's
some but and it's his replacement well
let's see here was a kicker though like
The Ultimate Comics were designed to be
like here's what these characters would
be like if they emerged in the current
day like that's what the the Ultimate
Comics were for he said of like throwing
it all the way back to like the 1960
Society it's like okay post 2000 what
would happen if Peter Parker was bitten
by a radioactive spider like yeah what
would happen if the Fantastic Four
gained their powers in like the 90s like
right what would that life be like and
yeah and that was a cool thing that's
why I like Miles Morales so much because
he came around in a time where you had a
lot of younger kids who were growing up
they were wanting to get into spider-man
I thought hey guys this is this is like
we're killing off Peter Parker here's
Miles Morales he comes from like an
underprivileged neighborhood so on and
so forth you know that kind of thing but
it was like it was a reflection of kids
in this day and age as opposed to a
reflection of kids like 50 years ago
which I think was a smart move and I
think that that people are ready to move
on to somebody besides Peter Parker I
think the biggest people I mean cuz
honestly your average moviegoers
probably wouldn't care they were just
like okay cool spider-man movie and they
would be like who's this and then
hopefully they would reasonably in like
the first few minutes and be like like
I'm miles miles like I'm a different
character different beats from Peter
Parker whatever I think a lot of
traditional spider-man fans would flip
they would be like USA Today would flip
I think that the people who were who
would spoil that on the day before it
comes out and the people who report on
it non comics fans who all outnumber us
by the way like the average reader of
your average crappy newspaper and your
average non comics reader they outnumber
us but also know that Peter Parker
spider-man the other problem is you have
to tell us origin again which nobody
wants to do well we can nobody has time
or patience for a friggin origin
especially for spider-man and the way
thing about like non comics fans is like
the three most recognizable characters
in the world a spider-man Batman and
Superman yes but for all of them the
recognizable thing is not what people
think is recognizable for spider-man
I know for a fact over here if you were
to say spider-man
they don't people don't actually think
about Peter Parker they just think about
spider-man the image right yeah so
that's why I always thought okay they
could get away from Magic Franklin or
Miles Morales and late in the case of
Superman people don't think about the S
on his chest they think about the red
briefs just like thisi need to bring
back the briefs but you know I never
really thought that the character no
we're switching gears all about the
Superman costume a little bit and that's
fair I think we've beaten this number
one I hate that Superman costume number
two I never would have expected those
trunks to be so important but they
really do break up the suit because
otherwise it just looks like I don't
know I mean I know that they used to be
wrestling trunks like that was they were
based off like the Kelly classic 30
strong man and that's where the
implication came from I know that like
Green Lantern doesn't have the trunks
and never did but they work for him I
never assumed I never expected like get
rid of the trunks and Superman just
looks like he's in his underwear which
but he does like it just looks really
weird to me it could be just because
he's so engrained in my brain and in and
for so many men of people like like me
or us who agree that it looks really
weird then it's like so ingrained in the
collective unconscious that we're like
well something is wrong with Superman's
costume we're weird it is red underwear
go but I think design and aesthetically
like know it like it breaks up the color
otherwise just blue and a white guy but
then like even pull the Supergirl
question that they recently released
they used the same color palette as the
Superman costume and I think it's the
color palette it's way too dark it is
very dark it's me it reminded me of the
brand and route Superman color palette
where it's like it's it's perfect and
then they turn the contrast up a little
bit and like my issue that Supergirl
costume is it's so boring if you're
gonna do Supergirl make I look like the
Sailor Moon
go home because no one's gonna take
Supergirl seriously anyway let's face it
well I give that series maybe a season
mate and that's you know
I don't know anything because I really
expected flash to fail but I was right
about Constantine well I will say this
kudos to the Superman Supergirl costume
they went with classic 80s comic-book
Superman logo that's true which is
really cool like it looks and it's not
some weird obnoxious variant because if
you look at every Superman s in every
movie in every TV incarnation yes is
just a little bit different like it's
almost there and if you're just if
you're checking your blind spot it looks
just like it but if you look at it hard
enough you're like something a little
off about that but the one that she's
wearing I am I was like that is the a
that is 1980 like four to 2000 Superman
as I was like that's kind of cool but
the palette is really dark so it's kind
of bizarre you know eventually they're
gonna get that symbol so a lot wrong is
just gonna be an upside down triangle
with s and Comic Sans in it oh
definitely no I mean that's yeah give it
another like 15 years and that's where
it's gone I mean like yeah I mean the
old s was the first s was just pretty
much a triangle with an S in it and then
eventually they were like let's blend
the s like it was the people got really
creative with it
well it's neat you see here's a problem
that I had with Superman's outfit before
with the red underwear all right
Superman is wearing a utility belt or
wearing a belt for real underwear like
he's wearing a belt to hold up his
underwear like to me the costume looks
silly like the old costume yeah the old
classic costume yeah well I may be a
classic but doesn't mean that it's not
antiquated and it was time I think to
let that go it was time to say okay like
let's move things in a different
direction and let's go ahead and just
change the France costume because
honestly it looked goofy you know what
that's actually a good point Rob you
know what they should do you know his in
and his his powers are pretty antiquated
- I mean flight invulnerability you
could see through walls we've seen all
that before practically every member the
Justice League has that power why don't
we give him some new powers take take
this for example what if we made him
electric
right just just Luke skin I know exactly
where you're going you're talking about
that I can like retain his powers cuz
he's all he's like a battery and he's
just gonna explode needs to wear a power
suit and the S can be like a lightning
bolt how about that colors there's a
huge difference between removing a
superhero wearing underwear on the
outside of his pants
and changing the entire makeup of his
character supervised underwear there is
that's not the defining attribute but
the underwear is a metaphor non comic
book readers Superman is defined by the
underwear that underwear is more
recognizable as Superman than the
[ __ ] s no I agree with that although
that may be a regional probably a
regional thing but there's more people
outside the US than inside the US I
walked around the world with Superman's
s like his logo if I tell you that oh
yeah and I took it I'd like that I took
like a picture of that in a picture of
red underwear and I said who do these
belong to
right off the bat who the symbol belongs
to and they'd be like I guess maybe it's
Superman
I don't but they would associate the
underwear with Superman because I'm
holding a logo of Superman over blue
tights I know pretty much everyone over
here that's old enough to know Superman
would go man tights like when you say
Superman people took up the red the red
underwear on blue tights here and that
is just a thing whenever I talk to non
comic book readers about Superman that
is one of the first things they talk
about so I do remember when they got rid
of them I remember hearing a lot of non
Comics readers may chime in shinning it
I don't know if they said it was the
defining attribute but I remember them
being like got rid of the underwear but
kind of I I took it as more of a
condescending like jab at us like oh
they got rid of his long in the out of
the underwear what are what are we gonna
make fun of him for now like that was
kind of a beat oh my god about it but
you know whatever they are changing it
again as I noticed I think that they're
going back to Action Comics Superman
outfit where he's gonna be wearing like
jeans
carpenter boots which um here's my
question about that cuz it was based off
of Grant Morrison's idea of like hey
we're gonna do Superman but he's gonna
be like on every guy and he'll have
he'll wear a Superman t-shirt if
Superman first appeared wearing that
what is the shirt like emulating like
who's s is that on the t-shirt like
Clark keeps getting he just gets poppin
I think he buys those shirts at like you
know because I was it's the same it's my
same problem with uh I'm not gonna go
into it but I will say in Man of Steel
there's a moment where Clark takes a red
towel and he wraps it around his neck
and he strikes the pose when the Sun is
like glaring over him and it's a
brilliant image whose the emulating what
what impression is he doing because
that's Superman there's no other
character that he is like pretending to
be either he's either either the the
director who is Zack Snyder is painfully
unaware of the reference he's making
like in a metatextual way where he's
like oh he's doing a Superman pose
yes but he doesn't know that there is I
think kids do that because Superman
exists Superman can't do that as a kid
because there's nothing before him or
young Clark Kent just knows he's gonna
be a god and he's just striking this
pose like one day I'll rule over all of
them and that's where the Superman pose
comes and then he's a bit of a [ __ ]
really isn't think well Man of Steel
Superman is kind of a that's kind of
like whoa see I went back and watch Man
of Steel because we were talking about
Man of Steel before and you were like
man like that movie sucks like man but
you're like it sucks and I went back and
watched it in the entire movie he was
like I know I have this godlike power
and I can pretty much do anything yeah
but I don't know what I want to do with
it but I do know I should save the world
but I don't know if I should and I'm
just gonna kind of rest on my laurels
and wait until a dude shows up in a ship
and then it starts killing people yeah
and destroying cities before I step in
and do anything
yeah I really like really there's
actually there's a how I should have
ended the whole thing about Man of
Steel's brilliant but the one thing I
like is when he's he's talking to his
mother and he just goes like why how am
I gonna stop Zod like if only I could go
to someone for guidance and she's like
you mean like a random priest he's like
no not a random priest that would be
weird know someone who knew Zod
personally
oh yeah my space dad and he's like hey
dad whose odd and then his dad just
brings him up to speed about everything
that Zod is like yeah that probably
should have happened but no everyone has
to be ridiculous okay we're talking with
man Steele moving on so we're talking
speculation we're talk about the things
that we were speculating about it this
is kind of in comics I feel like this is
kind of like the calm before the storm
before the great convergence and before
the the battle world emerges because
nothing is really coming out then we're
kind of like oh that's kind of cool we
should talk about that I feel so sorry
for comic resources and Newsarama right
now if you looked at the articles
they're just very like hey did you wait
hang on let me look that up really quick
cuz it's really funny I was looking at I
was reading them this morning I'm like
slow you got today huh yeah that's good
that's why I feel bad because there's
like there's like nothing out there's
it's like it's been like this
three-month long period oh yeah like
nothing since December and like that
makes things difficult for me because I
have a news day and at the moment I'm
just like what do I do it's some like
some stuff happening and like a big you
know it's one thing they can't let go of
is like x-files is getting a new season
we're not gonna talk about x-files I
just wanted to say like every every
other day I'm thinking they're like hey
x-files I'm like yeah I know
I heard all about it that's what it
feels like where they're coming nerds it
feels like they're constant saying like
hey guys in case you forgot like Marvel
and DC or reboot in their continuities
right hey did you know that's happening
real soon though we're gonna have some
news real soon we're really really hey
let me know when that happens I'll be
asleep they did release a new Fantastic
Four poster which was the a still from
the trailer yeah this is the news we
have OH
it says like change is coming I'm like
crap like well okay okay so we're
talking about that before before we
started the whole podcast and I think
like I told Sal I think that's the
negative zone and it makes perfect sense
because as far as I understand it like
they're drawing on the ultimate
Fantastic Four continuity to launch the
film and like they're young yeah
well but see member like the negative
zone was like prominent in terms of how
they gained their power so we're like
hey here's a portal and they're like BAM
negative zone back to reality and
they're like oh my god we got all my
powers and that's just kind of it it's a
lot easier to do then like having them
like go into space and encounter cosmic
rays and have those like because when
you when you think about it like how do
cosmic rays make one person a rock
monster and one person look like
stretchy yeah I know but I think like we
saw I mean like as much as those other
movies there's other fantastic four
movies all three of them are so terrible
and like two story kind of highlights
the fundamental flaw with showing a
modern version of classic Fantastic Four
like let's get all of them on a cuz
because they had to get them all on a on
a spaceship and have them get bombarded
by cosmic rays but in today's world
where they be able to see them coming
from like years ago like from years from
now like hey we better not like go there
because I can actually see when cosmic
rays are coming like just yeah there's
an inherent issue with with with the
classic sixties origin of cosmic rays
which Stan Lee clearly didn't know what
they were and but I could easily be
fixed if they just remained them and
called them Galactus ways that was my
question like it like when the movie
came out and they said okay guys like
we're gonna base this on cosmic rays I'm
like so is Galactus like sitting on the
other side of the universe and he's just
like cosmic rays and which since I'm
flying out this like
after eating a planet and those creeks
uh although that would be brilliant if
they did that'd be hilarious
I'm surprised Hickman hasn't done that
yet but uh good luck his work what is
with needing to have dr. doom have super
powers why can't he just be Iron Man
mm-hmm like what he needs be smart and
make a really cool suit I was gonna go
yeah but if you look at Children's
Crusade where he had powers like and
then I remembered it was like he used
them like one page and they almost
killed himself and was like well you
know every time he gets no I'm nipa
powers what do you like
after the Silver Surfer and siphons his
powers or when he goes to the medieval
times and talks to work in the face and
gets powers via magic or when he when he
absorbed the powers of the Scarlet Witch
like oh or when he took the beyonders
powers like well first of all fix his
face and then second of all he tries to
take over the world yes he did like but
see it was funny it was funny in secret
wars because he was like he's like now I
have the powers of the Beyonder and and
I can do pretty much anything and I'm
second to only the one above all and I'm
probably better than him and so he's
like I'm just going to like relax
because the power would run amuck he had
to be ever vigilant and stay away no no
no but I mean like if you go back and
like after he gained his powers like if
you go back and read Secret Wars like
he's just chilling inside of his like
it's not like doom in the database yeah
and base yeah whatever they called like
he's just chilling in there and like the
like Ulysses Klaw is there's like oh my
god like you know be careful with your
powers all that kind of stuff in there
be honors like you know what like I'm
gonna take over the body of Leslie's
claw and get my powers back yeah what he
does and yeah and it was kind of silly
but but no I think I figured right on
that like I think having a character
who's just so incredibly smart that he
can basically like outmaneuver even
reaches the Hanging Alliance and his
powers at every turn I think would be
awesome and that's in and of itself a
comic book movie trope that being your
villain or your antagonist is a person
who has
our envy which sucks but that's where we
are like a character who's like I want
to have powers and those people do but I
can't have them so I'll invent powers
using my vast intelligence and
technology skills and then be a bad guy
and it's like how anti Batman of like
that was did you guys ever see sky high
huh oh yeah I like sky high really why
the movies not horrible and it does a
pretty it does a very galaxy quest job
of sending up the superhero genre while
also cementing it in a pretty decent
story and especially decent if we were
looking at it as like a movie for kids
you know 12 and up like I think that's a
fun flick but it went in for me the
wrong direction because there's a moment
where the main kit because you got
Superman Wonder Woman I don't remember
the other characters names who cares
they got a Superman and Wonder Woman and
they have a kid and the kid has no
powers and he's reached the age where
he's supposed to have powers but the
powers haven't come out yet and
everyone's really bummed out right like
that's you know Superman won't I won't
have a kid and he's going to superhero
school where all the other superheroes
kids go to school which is in the clouds
or something and you have this this
character who's likeable and fun and
cool and he has friends across the aisle
he's got friends who are sidekick
material and he's got friends who are
superhero material and he has no powers
and Superman and Wonder Woman are really
bummed out about it and so they put him
into sidekick Academy like into like the
crappy electives with the other
sidekicks who have no powers or lame
powers and then he manifests Superman
powers and then he like learns that
being popular and having powers is great
like that's the whole basis of the story
more or less that's it I mean like no
it's a really though he learns a lesson
and he actually learns like you know
there's no hierarchy of powers and like
everyone is useful but what he could
have done
was study hard and invent paths like I
thought he was going to like suddenly
have because it wouldn't what happens
was he manifest powers and it's like he
has like all of them like he has like
flight or not flight because like
super-strength and whatever it seemed a
little too good to be true
and so I thought like he and the
sidekicks like invented the powers like
work together they were like we got this
thing we were gonna use but no would
have believed that we had these powers
so we had no like person to use it as
our vessel and then they would give him
like this super suit that would give him
powers and then like he'll become
popular and then he'll like let them
become popular and then of course it
would blow up in their faces and
everyone would learn a lesson about
being jerks about like you know that
doesn't matter like there's no such
thing as being super powerful it's just
about being like a good person or
something like so what is describing
it's Mean Girls yeah girls with
superpowers we're like where the kid
teaches the the superheroes that like
the real superpower is your brain but no
your real superpower is your ability to
fly and have superpowers I think I've
done that right from the start because I
remember this movie weirdly vividly yes
exactly but they could have done that
because his neighbor she was in the
sidekick class because she refused to
use her powers for fighting and she had
like the ability to make plants grow as
high and as strong as she wanted she's
really had like an amazing power and the
power couldn't have been from the brain
right from the start so she got rid of
her that which means they were they had
to get rid of love interest number two
yeah and that woulda never happened
exactly yeah that was my point was just
like they like that was an opportunity
for them to use to to turn these the
soon to be powerless villain like the
the power envy villain trope on its ear
but they could have turned him into the
power and be villain yeah yeah that
would be cool too but no we have
everyone syndrome where yeah I hate the
power and even a little bit and a
villain trope just because it makes me
of Eddie Brock and just who the [ __ ] is
jealous Peter Parker well you know what
I could imagine looking on the outside
like Dan Slott actually perfectly
encapsulates it in a spider-man Human
Torch miniseries Human Torch is like I
looked at your life you're Peter Parker
life where you have women fighting Lou
tripping over themselves to be with you
all of them are tens and you like get to
go to school and you've got like a
family loves you and you have like it
you're a famous photographer you know I
just wanted that and Peter burgers like
are you your mind like my girlfriend was
killed on a bridge by an [ __ ] in a
purse like well it's not great but see
that that to me is is the big kicker
like I think that that the problem that
they have when they make these films is
they think okay like you're
super-powered characters we need to have
someone who's as powerful as they are or
more powerful that way it's like oh yeah
like they overcame you know almost
insurmountable odds or something like
that not at all like I think the fact
that they could make a character like
doom who would be as intelligent as he
is who's just like looked yes my mother
was like a sorceress basically and I
inherited some of her abilities but
pretty much everything I have now like
everything I know is yeah it's like I
worked hard to get it and like that I
think would make him a far better
character because you could do so much
character development with that but the
problem is they're like ah well like
Fantastic Four and like dooms so what
does heaven like troll the internet and
then fight the Fantastic Four and then
superpowers to where he shoots
electricity or something yeah and that's
a mess dumb I think it takes away from
how effective and how awesome his
character could be and instead we just
get like this water down piece of
nonsense but yeah I don't know so anyway
so um actually well getting into the
speculation now after we're what like
like 30 minutes into this talking about
sky-high um okay so so getting into
Secret Wars um one of the things we
talked about before we started the
podcast here was the whole hail Hydra
event and the whole hail Hydra story I
think it's gonna be really really cool
because for those of you guys were
unaware hail hydra is gonna be one of
the post can or one of the titles during
secure Wars and hopefully it'll last
after secret Wars where we will see what
the world looks like if Hydra had taken
over I guess four of the United States
long before the presidents even came
together to Foreman like I'm assuming it
takes place sometime during like pre or
during the American Revolution but I
didn't know that I thought it was just
like what if hydride one like no no well
they're saying that it like you know
back when you had the age of freemasons
and all that kind of stuff Oh like what
if they were Hydra based and so you know
once I guess the United States won its
war or whatever the case may be like it
became a Hydra territory from there how
you just spread outward into the world
so that you have a world that has ran
and governed by Hydra what was really
cool about this is it struck me you know
it seemed very similar to the
Philadelphia Experiment you guys ever
see that hmm you guys ever see the
Phillip cells not paying a bit of
attention I'm amazed I didn't catch the
title you see the Philadelphia
Experiment no I don't know anything
about okay so the Philadelphia
Experiment was it was actually a couple
movies but it was based off this
supposed story about how the government
was experimenting with like invisibility
how to make ships invisible and in the
film they made a ship invisible but they
actually sent it back in time okay so
yeah you had this guy named name heard a
guy came over what is that is like Paula
her dagger something I thought I can't
what his name is but part two deals with
the deals with what would have happened
if a Nazi scientist gained this
technology and then sent like a
futuristic fighter jet into the past of
World War two and the Nazi Party won
World War two and so the United States
is a Nazi territory and it was really
really really cool concept without
really kind of struck me as that same
thing but my question is what kind of
world would you have with Hydra running
it because the only character that we
know of that was part of Hydra and then
defected and joined the superheroes was
Jessica drew was spied on like she was
on Hydra spy at one point on and then
yeah then she became like like Nick Fury
like turned her against Hydra basically
and then she became triple agent wasn't
stupid
didn't she start her life with well
start her life with Hydra because she
was knocked out when she was like six
years old and then woke up and Hydra
were looking after her and then she
eventually rejoined them for a little
bit
Jessica joy is a weird character she is
like like she was part of the hand for a
while which like it had Hydra at some
point and then like she that's that's
all right that's the weird thing about
Hydra like at some point along the line
you had Hydra like way back in the past
and then it just kind of fizzled and
then you had the hand which rebooted
Hydra and then that kind of went away
and then Baron von Strucker was like
okay Hydra and like that's where Hydra
runs up until now and and that was that
wasn't so like pretty much the only
thing that anybody ever needs to care
about when it comes to Hydra is like
everything after Baron von Strucker like
that's the only thing that really
matters but nonetheless like she was
part of the hand for a while but it's
it's it'd be a really cool concept
because right now I mean you don't
really have that like you have Hydra
constantly bumping heads but to see like
darker superheroes and the question oh
yes Hydra versions of yeah yeah like
like Hydra Captain America and Hydra
Iron Man my question would be who would
they fight against I mean you'd have to
have some kind of like resistance
movement I guess well we've seen the
front cover of the first issue which
includes Captain America's son yeah and
like who's standing you know and he's
the only one he's like he's he's dressed
as Captain America he's got like the
shield and everything
I guess I'm guessing it'll be something
like he's he comes out of the dimension
that they he came from originally and
like you know he's like this is wrong
like this isn't right and then he fights
it every don't know it'll be interesting
I I can't even imagine what they're
gonna do with it looking like from the
front cover there like spotlights
looking everywhere and I'm looking like
right now so it could be like a North
Korea kind of situation where everyone's
just kind of sectioned off from each
other yeah I'm and I just sort of mean
like manipulating people culturally I
don't know that's true I can imagine
like that'd be yeah you could have yeah
I mean it feels like it's gonna be one
of those stories like any of the
alternate reality Marvel books like
spider-man war or something where it's
like you got these characters and they
live in their own different places and
it's just all under the same umbrella of
this premise so you're gonna have like a
young Hydra spider-man character who's
like parents you know I mean they'll be
like
like a DC Elseworlds book like Superman
red Sun we got like or you know Batman's
parents were anti Superman radicalist
s-- and you know they were I'd see that
as being kind of what they're gonna do
yeah yeah I don't know let's see that
and that to me is really kind of the
cool thing because my question is like
how far they gonna go with this because
we know what they're gonna have like
during Secret Wars my question is going
coming out to see your wars like are
they gonna because you can't have the
same thing like forever they got to
introduce new stuff and what I'm hoping
is they draw on some of the interesting
elements like for example I think it was
part of an age of Ultron what-if series
there was like a five part series called
hung called age of alternative yeah
there they were a lot of them were
really really bad but the one that I
thought was kind of interesting was the
one with the Punisher as Captain America
where at least I think that was it where
he were they I don't maybe was that one
was that one or there's an old what-if
where he was cast America which is fun
we'll see this one was like a relatively
new and he was somewhere online Captain
America got killed and that'll member if
it was part of age of Ultron or a
different story but what they do is they
say like American needs what the country
needs a Captain America right and like
they don't know Steve Rogers is dead all
they know is that he's just not there
and so they were like we needed someone
to stand in its place and so they're
like you Frank how so I like the best
person to do it why I don't know because
that's what we want to see yes that's
exactly just like like reasons but
here's reasons and they're like you have
Frank Castle play Captain America and
he's really really brutal about it it's
actually progressing when he does it
initially but then he grows into it and
then after that you end up with like
this army of Captain America they have
call out the Captain America Corps which
is kind of whatever but nonetheless like
it was it was a cool concept for the
time and yeah I would like to see a
Captain America core of some kind
although obviously not stemming from
like a stupid basis on Frank Castle
being being being Captain America but I
think that in some capacity they're
gonna have to find some way to keep
things relatively interesting after
seeker wars because going forward I mean
how many of those stories do we have
could they really keep like I don't see
kill Craven so I think they're looking
at as kind of like a number one they're
like spider-gwen sold like gangbusters I
guess
can try anything and see if it works but
also I think they were kind of like yeah
we're gonna try it out but I don't think
it's gonna like I don't think they're
planning on most I'm having like a long
run like they were announcing how they
were like we we can sold 33 titles yeah
but you're also gonna then come out with
23 titles and you've cancelled like the
lowest selling books that were cancelled
like it's it's not gonna be a like
they're just gonna bring back everything
that they that's in them that's in the
main stable they're just gonna do 50 to
it or they're just gonna throw it all
buncha titles and then if if one of them
sells like gangbusters that you didn't
expect they'll just keep it going
it's just a [ __ ] of a pilot program
yeah if Hydra world works we'll see a
Hydra world miniseries because there's
no way everyone who reads Marvel is
gonna read a Hydra world or whatever
they're calling it hail Hydra or
something that Hydra series for more
than 13 issues yeah so you know they're
you're gonna have a cool trade of that
like 1602 awesome idea it's cool that
we're gonna go back to the universe
we've seen 1602 sequel eyes and it
didn't do nearly as well maybe cuz the
Gaiman wasn't writing it or maybe
because 1602 works in this amount of
story and then that's all you can really
do with it but we'll see and but even
then like I don't think 1602 is gonna
last more than 13 issues you know but
Avengers might I feel like it's it's all
just a pilot program and we're just
gonna see what what sells and what
doesn't
well thanks place especially at Marvel
unless it's got Avengers or x-men in the
title it's just so hard to sell it oh
yeah well yeah that's because you have
like I mean the popularity of the Marvel
Comics at least now are based on the
film's like that's what draws people in
like longtime readers already have their
mainstays like people like I mean people
who've been reading comics for like like
us for a length amount for a lengthy
amount of time like we already know who
our favorites are we're like okay like
we're gonna read these characters and
we're not really going to branch out to
anybody else because we didn't like them
before why would we like them now well
and there's people out there who are
like we have their characters who are
who
who have a flash in the pan lifespan
where like there are people who really
really really want to see a
cloak-and-dagger series come back and
like you know maybe once in a while they
get what like their Deathlok fans
there's Iron Fist fans now that mean
Iron Fist is on the same level as
freakin Deathlok but Iron Fist can't
sustain a Mane like a a maxi or an
ongoing series it's not say that it's
not a great character and the miniseries
people love or the series that have been
cancelled I've been you know beloved and
really great Hawkeye another great book
that they felt they needed to reboot
because I guess sales for slumping
that's that fractions Hawkeye or
fraction just left the book I don't know
which one is which but yeah the
interesting thing about the iron fist
situation is they've got the TV show
coming out or the Netflix show ya know
I'm sure so I think like once that comes
out looking at the popularity of stuff
like orange is the new black and
everyone loves anything that's made by
Netflix these days yeah I think going
off with that popularity that might just
redefine how we see I infer this was
like it's true and hopefully Marvel is
smart about rolling out their trades
properly because I remember when
guardians the galaxy was coming out
there were no guardians trades yeah
Brent like they had to reprint like
there were no guardians trades being
printed at that time except for Bendis
--is the space Avengers vol 1 though I
have to say that kind of helped me
because no one could really get into
guardians lights oh my goodness you've
got into the galaxy leading up to the
movie coming out got a lot of use it was
really happy about yeah oh yeah it's oh
yeah no yeah we all kind of jumped on
the butt but see here's the thing if
model was smart and and I'm hoping they
choose to do this Marvel's best bet with
regards to like Luke Cage and Jessica
Jones and iron fist and and well not
really daredevil because he's already
such a big name but they're like he's is
his title selling well but is it a top
title I don't think so no no but but
enough people know who daredevil
is that they're gonna say okay if
Daredevils getting his own TV show like
okay then I'll check out the other to
see how those do like I hear doubling
people in there were people I knew
people who never heard of daredevil
really yeah I don't know anybody who
hasn't heard of dirt if I really I do
know people who have never heard of him
ever there was like when the first we
came out when the and like granted that
was 12 years ago but when the first
daredevil movie came out a good friend
of mine who was significantly older than
me so he had longer to know about
daredevil who's also a nerd like Star
Wars Star Trek Dukes of Hazzard plugged
into the zeitgeist so he had the I had
access he goes are they really that
desperate for superheroes they're now
gonna start making like the blind
superhero who's daredevil he assumed
that because of the spider-man movie
studios were just making up characters
really the daredevil had been created by
the studio to appeal to like bleeding
heart liberals I was like no sir came
out like are you freaking kidding me
yeah like I came out with the arm owners
of spider-man and full of years so trust
me never underestimate the the populace
to not know what the hell were talking
about I guess man but let's see like if
what I think they should do and if
they're if what they're gonna do is try
to boost sales for daredevil or
especially if they're gonna try to like
introduce stories that revolve around
Luke Cage Jessica Jones or even the
defenders yeah start off while releasing
companion comics just say like here's
the companions to what's going on in the
Netflix series which they're really
they're really good at doing that
they're really good at doing that with
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe films
she knows companion stories are really
really good like the ones that I into
Captain America they give you his
backstory before he became Captain
America back when Steve Rogers was a kid
those are really really really cool
stories but if they can make companion
comics that are interesting then I think
that will kind of go towards boosting
thing
up for daredevil sales and actually
bring people in like attract readers and
ruckus prospective readers into a Luke
eight but see I think you're kind of
right about about like about iron fist
because iron fist could barely hold his
own comic when it was him and Luke Cage
and Heroes for Hire people were just
kind of like well I mean you know it's
whatever like people didn't really get
into that too much and we saw that at
first on the if you're talking about the
70s like that era of move like niche
movies yeah so yeah movies that were in
Chinese and then they've dubbed them in
English so it'll be like I'm going to
kill you but I was gonna say can we talk
about the all-new all-different Avengers
yeah you guys are not familiar one of
the titles they're rolling out after
battle world or during battle world or
whatever hell it takes place is the
all-new all-different avengers this is
for my money I think it's the only
Avengers title yeah it probably is I
mean I haven't heard of any other titles
being announced there's well I know that
they a next which if we can just take a
moment is a terrible title yeah they're
like it's an all-female Avengers title
which we won't it's the only Avengers
title that we have never called Avengers
yeah like we've had books that have
nothing to do like Illuminati that like
New Avengers Illuminati was a miniseries
they're not avenge like but but ain't
but an all-female team we will not call
we will imply it with a logo we won't
actually call it Avengers which is
stupid but neat idea I guess terrible
title but a next is one of the Avengers
teams and the all-new all-different
Avengers is seems to be their main title
it's certainly gonna be their flagship
book that they're releasing on Free
Comic Book Day which is in the first
Saturday in May which everyone should go
to because sub or support your local
comic book stores um man let me tell you
something I don't know how I feel about
an all-new all-different all over
vendors not really just because of where
the lineup seems to be but because the
characters that they've introduced so
far are characters I just don't
okay here's a really good example so
when for number one came out the thorn
is a female Thor number the female for
number one came out female for sold like
a hundred twenty thousand copies all
right within the second issue it dropped
about 40 percent like now there's always
a drop-off between the initial entry or
between issue number one and issue
number two what was speculation yes yes
well because the question was what's
gonna happen in issue number one that's
going to make me want to read issue
number two yeah alright and issue number
one everybody want another question
who's this new female version of Thor
they didn't tell anybody and the sort
wasn't even that important it was just
like well four can't lift his hammer and
then at the very end of it all they're
like will that work and left his hammer
frost giants are coming back oh my god
what are gonna do and then somebody's
like they're always there should all
just be a thor and she picks up the
hammer done and done right was not that
it was they really screwed the pooch
with issue number one of thor like they
should have put a lot more in there
should have been a lot more important in
truth it probably should have been like
a giant size issue but nonetheless like
in fact is that they just kind of kind
of at least i felt like they kind of
screwed it up but in any event there's a
40 percent drop off between like issue
number one in issue number two now when
you compare that to like all new Captain
America
all new Captain America had a 58 percent
drop off between issue number one and
issue number two people had care no one
cared about the all new Captain America
there were a handful of people maybe and
that is it
so I don't understand why they're
choosing on the thor especially when
they're launching the thor core and
they're gonna watch the thor core it
would make perfect sense to me to put
the all-new floor in there to give us
the identity of this all-new thor why
they would throw her in an Avengers
title unless she's gonna be in both both
yeah well none none I'm not really sure
and somebody made a good point yeah the
current for the female floor is
outselling the thor odin's son yeah
there's a there's a reddit post somebody
made a comparison chart where they were
like well store god of thunder sold this
many and thor number one sold this many
and if you look at the graphs like
you'll see that you know god of thunder
was a better title or something yelling
out right yeah okay well let's also talk
about sales and like stuff like let's
you know go like this version of thor is
also one
so it's gonna do better in to hasn't
been around for like 50 years
and some people were ready for a change
this is the change they got we'll see
what happens when the series continues
on but nonetheless I don't think it was
the best decision but regardless the
lineup they revealed so far with Kamala
Khan and with the new Thor I don't I
haven't read anything by Kamala Khan
right nothing and I had no desire to
fast as a coronary and I do this but if
you guys are not familiar what we're
talking about you should Google the
all-new all-different Avengers you'll
get a cut you'll get a cover page that
has most of the characters silhouetted
the two that they've revealed are female
Thor and Kamala Khan MS Marvel and it
looks like they're fighting radioactive
man so I'm not the one from we also have
these one two three four five characters
one of those obviously Miles Morales
spider-man is who are going to be the
all-new all-different Avengers and it's
been speculated that they're the only
they're all characters have never been
Avengers before oh that blows my
carryout the hotels like you know maybe
if some of them are ultimate versions
like it doesn't count but but fast go go
for you were gonna because he's robbed
is marvel at all I've read three issues
of his Marvel and was not thrilled then
kind of was turned around by it um I
kind of dig the character more than I
liked the book which is funny like I
like seeing her interact I like her
personality I just wasn't interested in
her universe at that point but should I
come on act pieces she's one of my
favorite these models one of my favorite
books that comes out every month oh one
second sure so with with respect to
these these okay that's called not down
with theater lingo okay it was my cat or
something she against my door and it was
a cat yeah he says I'm excited to see
her branch out do you all
things because she had that thing
Wolverine and then you nothing so it's
interesting to see her interact with
okay other characters but I was looking
at this silhouette and for a second I
was like top right-hand corner kind of
like Witkin silhouette from the second
run of the young adventures is Wiccan
going to be a nurse and then no Avengers
so but the Avengers were never
considered official Avengers so I don't
know that counts I don't know they what
was it in Children's Crusade they made a
statue for a few characters that fell in
well they made it Cassie but she was in
the Secret Avengers oh yeah she was a
young Avenger too
she was like an Avenger but then she was
also a full-fledged Avenger while she
was a young Avenger oh okay but like
Wiccan and speed wasn't and then Hawkeye
she was never a full-fledged Avenger
yeah sorry yeah which is time for it's
time for Kate Bishop to be on like I'm
disappointed she's not on this team yeah
but well she could be I mean well unless
you can fly look can we look at this and
just kind of play with this with these
silhouettes cuz like it's you know that
can be kind of fun in its own right
because you know damn it's ridiculous
cuz I got I mean like you can tell the
top right I feel like that's a cape like
it looks like it's a century esque
character mm-hmm
well I feel like definitely it's it's
Captain America or Captain Falcon in the
middle there you think so oh yeah it's
got a way he's got wings it looks like
that could be a shield on his left oh
yeah or it's or it's a repulsor blasts
from the eye from the obviously Iron Man
character on the Left Wow see I don't
think that's well maybe that we'll see I
wasn't sure like actually I think it'd
be funny if that was star-lord um the I
mean obviously the kid down at the
bottom the one of the bottom left here
corner right hand corner is Sam
Alexander oh yeah that's that's Nova no
question yeah and then see the one so
you have all right so you're talking
about the Captain America care do you
talk about the one on the left hand side
I mean the dead dead center yeah yeah
that well that was great yeah that was
gonna be all Newtown Sam Wilson yes
Allison um the Iron Man character you
talk about that's gonna be the one on
the left hand side on the left hand side
yeah that's clearly an Iron Man helmet
the one on the right hand side that one
has we confused with that in some degree
because they have a cape could very well
be some spin on like the vision but if
what you're saying is true that like the
all the characters who were supposed to
be in this all-new all-different
Avengers were never Avengers well then
obviously wouldn't be visually it could
be it could be the iron lad vision that
was a vision I did actually think that I
was like maybe could be him I mean like
and we're I'm right by the way dead
center middle or bottom center that's
Miles Morales spider-man oh yeah I mean
I don't know who else it would be a this
cover thinking what does this remind me
of what does this remind it looks a lot
like I just realize it looks like a lot
like the cover of the New Teen Titans oh
really
yeah for me it looks like really bad
Photoshop looks like they just this is
like they had just I'll draw all these
character separately and then I'll just
cut and paste them all into this brand
information like yeah and you know how I
know that like I'm probably not gonna
take the story seriously because they're
fighting general chin like they're
fighting radioactive man right I mean I
you know I'm like okay like whatever
like radio that command wasn't it was
like part of the Thunderbolts during a
frickin Civil War and I I just didn't
really care that much right oh no I
don't you I don't care about radioactive
man at all yeah you know so I don't know
um although you know what like I didn't
care about absorbing man but I really
liked is going back but like with the
New Avengers when the New Avengers had
to fight absorbing man and the New
Avengers were like spider-man Wolverine
Spider Woman and Luke Cage and he's like
are you kidding me yeah
we'll see who did this snow was was it
was at the Recker
dad doesn't matter but it was it was an
Avengers level villain who was like you
none of you can beat me actually but see
the whole reason for that though the
ruin and you're talking about the absorb
and the whole reason for that though was
because they took his character
seriously right they gave his character
like some legitimacy in that story are
you talking about man that can absorb
any for like any material right and put
themself into it like like why would he
be anything less than one of the highest
highest uh I guess yeah one of the
highest level threats for the Avengers
yeah I mean the guy could touch out a
man to him and take on that uh mantium
form oh wow that is that is exactly the
same cover yeah it's the exact same
cover so I don't know if they're that's
a joke yeah you don't know the cover you
guys just posted yeah they do to teen
titans cover from like the 80s oh wow
are you serious it could it be like an
old teenage team and that's just like a
shout out to it it's kind of cool I like
that idea although young although female
Thor doesn't seem to be a teenager I
think she's 19 okay counts depending on
what who she actually is that is that is
the exact same cover and that's a little
disappointing too yeah that's just a
little disappointing I mean looking at
looking at those two different things
and the thing is that is an ongoing Teen
Titans cover they do that every few
years with the current team yes so I
don't know if he'll D see you again
about that yeah well they do it like
sometimes they don't really they don't
they they don't usually have an issue
with like with cover omage azure like
cover like Diggs there's an issue of
amazing spider-man where he's literally
doing the action comics number one image
where he's like all Makar oh really
yeah oh wow also yeah what was it raul
Vegas as Sam Wilson is not a teenager so
yeah not enough not even a little bit I
don't know well though we've also seen
what was it the the new Ultimates the
people who were like with with cloak and
dagger and bombshell and Myles Morelle
that book is freakin terrible well let's
see that's that's why I'm really worried
about what happens after Secret Wars
because a lot of what we've been getting
from Marvel Comics recently hasn't been
that great that's true and they're all
they're all their attentions being
diverted to this freakin event to all of
their metaphorical eggs are being placed
into one basket will that may very well
be true and it could be that once you've
got worse kicks off it'll be like one of
the some of the best storytelling their
Marvel's done in years where's the truth
like wouldn't be too hard the best
Marvel story you mean better than axis
how is that possible yeah but um but no
I think that I can't put links in my own
comment section of my own livestream
Thank You YouTube I can't no just google
it well here I'll put in the description
you guys said well no oh yeah yeah but
um no I think that that this this is
this is one of the big problems that
I've had this is why I've been well I
haven't read a lot of the current like a
lot of the newer stories some of my hat
some of them I haven't but like all new
Captain America
I got current with that but the problem
is that that with Sam Wilson the only
thing I found interesting about Sam
Wilson with what they did with uh new
Captain America is they retold his
origin yeah I like that that was a
really cool thing were they they were
talking about how his parents were
killed and like his his father was
killed when he was trying to save a guy
and they were the inspiration for him
becoming the person that he did that was
really cool stuff but but a lot of the
other things that went on I just didn't
really I couldn't really identify and I
think it was because it happened so fast
that it was quite literally Captain
America number 24 Steve Rogers he was an
old man number 25 BAM all new Captain
America I actually kind of led into it
but none of what they did in terms of
this story like this passing of the
mantle was really and like an intriguing
story like all that happened like this
this is literally all that happened
Captain America goes to dimensions II
like arnim zola's dimension he like
steals arnim zola's son and then adopts
him at his own and then gets sent back
to the regular dimension and then he
fights like mind bubble and then
whatever
dude's name is it he uses his like
tentacles to take delight steal the
Super Soldier Serum he grows old nets it
right like literally that's what happens
and that's why I didn't really dig it
that much because I was just kind of
like you know what it's not very what
seems really kind of like an
afterthought like they wanted to get rid
of his powers but they didn't have any
plan as to what they were gonna they
were like well we have but we have this
direction for Captain America like he
just got out of the Z dimension Z he has
this kid maybe we're gonna do something
with that no no I would like to see
Captain America loses his powers goes
into depression because he feels [ __ ]
useless cuz he's now an old man yeah
then starts using something like mutant
growth hormone to try and get his powers
back and we see it couldn't go through
some kind of addiction through that see
that would be a cool dark story
especially if you would written by Greg
Pak that would be a cool dark story but
instead like here's here's how Steve
Rogers reacts to all new Captain America
one he's like Pat's him on the back
because nobody saw that coming and then
too like he's hanging out with Sharon
Carter I think it is and she was like
let him like leave Malone and do his job
you're not Captain America anymore and
he's out fishing and he's kind of like
okay punch Ironman again yeah and that's
it now obviously we're gonna get captain
this is this is one of the funny things
they're doing mr. Wars is obviously
we're gonna get a Steve Rogers Captain
America back he's in Planet Hulk o100 is
he come on yeah he's run devil dinosaur
I haven't seen that cover like what was
yeah it's just a big buff Captain
America vraja'
riding devil dinosaur with Hulk's and
stuff really yep I mean there's I guess
I mean that's the only one well there
yeah there's one where he's like holding
a shield yeah oh yeah there's like all
the whole cans punching down on him
mm-hmm but yeah okay that's cool
whatever that's one version of a like
but aural I'm still even clearer about
what the hell this is like are we may
declare like what are they all different
universes that all take place in one
physical plane
they have another like like you're
selling here's what a sec Baskin explain
it okay so what is you know like in
Futurama in one episode they go to the
edge of the universe they look and they
see the cowboy universe I think that's
exactly what we're having okay oh yeah
we're mostly or it's ever been explained
to me thank you and see like here's like
with regards to see I don't even know
why like I don't know the bases were
planted whole my assumption is once you
have like battle or once you have what
do we say that was they had war zones
once you have war zones we're like the
universe's or I guess the territories
start being divvied up among like all
these different people that's what I
think you're gonna see the like although
all the hoaxes were like well I guess we
should all just kind of like live
together in like one giant territory I
mean I don't know that's what that's
what they're gonna do I don't understand
how all that's gonna end up together
which I guess it all makes sense during
sugar wars or at least you hope it will
Amy yeah maybe it'll make sense I mean I
just I imagine like this giant migration
of like hooks and they're like we claim
this land in the name of the incredible
hooks and they all just live there like
I don't see how else is gonna happen
with us that's how I imagine it and
that's my concern is is the idea came to
their that they said okay at some point
along the line like we're gonna have to
change something and they say okay let's
just like reboot the continuity because
we have to find a way to like roll the
Marvel Cinematic Universe into the
Marvel comic universe which is gonna
happen oh and and they're like we got to
do this also why don't we just like do
it with everything let's just like
reboot our continuity and it's all new
number ones and then we'll change things
up a bit you know and have you know so
on and so forth yada yada yada the
problem is I think they spend so much
time are they spending so much time
focusing on that that it's not like how
can we do it in a way that makes sense
yeah and that's that's gonna be my
concern but again like I mean is it's
like Brevoort said that like Secret Wars
number two it's supposed to be this like
mega like four times the normal size of
a giant sized issue of a comic so we're
supposed to be huge in scale and so I'm
curious to see like what I mean that
that's supposed to show us everything
happening getting it all forget
ujin's their comics explained I don't
know what the hell's happening but I'll
make it all make sense it'll probably
take a couple videos to do but I'll make
it all make sense there's gonna be it's
not that's gonna be the crate like
that's why does it for those of you guys
who are watching that's why we're
getting like all this stuff out of the
way now so that like once Secret Wars
you converging stars isn't looking focus
only on that I'll finally start
explaining it in 2020 much much later
yeah I still haven't even done anything
in the new 52
really yeah yeah it's not that's
interesting well have you been reading
that girl oh I've been reading stuff in
the new 52 and I've been reading stuff
that's in Marvel now I just write about
doing it yeah interesting yep but anyway
guys um we've been ranting on for about
an hour or so so we're gonna go ahead
and and I guess bring this one to an end
right um slowly way so what does
everybody have going on this week good
question yeah so we got to you can look
forward to a history video and a who are
our video and then a lot of x-men stuff
because I've been reading lots of really
old new x-men stuff nice like 2001
really old 2003 so we get to see we get
to see like all new x-men or I guess new
x-men and yeah then we go the crazy
things about Morrison's run man Morrison
was like hey guys I'm ready for the
x-men now I'm almost like alright
awesome what are you gonna do it's like
I want you to change the name silly
outfits or put them all in Peppa yeah
yeah totally
as soon as Morrison left they made fun
of the leather thing the leather was
intimidating people over here on the
newly titled comic pop if you're not
familiar with changed our name from TV
little house to comic pop you can visit
us at Comic Bob net which just takes us
to the YouTube channel it's all a ruse
but yeah we're doing
we got a new back issues coming out on
Thursday we have an off-the-rack we
talked at Howard the Duck by popular
demand
hard to imagine saying out loud we have
a comic commentary that we're doing on
the Generation X 1996 movie putting out
soon thank you that's the only way you
can watch it because we watched it with
no commentary and it was almost done
watch but it was also incredibly
mind-blowing so you explained this movie
to me and I've still got this because I
know like movie TV pilots were a thing
back then yeah but the only one I've
actually seen was really successful
which was thus agreement of the Teenage
Witch one oh yes no yeah it's nothing
like that no it's more like if Joel
Schumacher's Batman Robin director if he
directed like a Lois and Clark meets
Dawson's Creek movie with cursing in it
it's really bizarre and and for April
Fool's week we're doing something
totally insane
yes Mennella Fool's is coming up and
it's amazing how fast everything's
moving like it's freaking nuts like
Christmas special because it's Christmas
now goodie actually had to remind me
like like I was almost telling on like
man like I'm getting ready to do like
Deadpool kills Deadpool like I need to
finish that up he's like you know Secret
Wars is starting in like a week I was
like what and he was like yeah dude like
Secret Wars like the like all that
starts in like like a week or two yeah
like like like Avengers like Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers come to an and
like the next week and I was like uh
well Wow so I guess we got that coming
up and then don't the convergence title
start yep yep they all kick off no I'm
sorry yeah Secret Wars is in May
convergence isn't is in April so um so
yeah that's gonna be nuts that's gonna
be so
it's gonna be pandemonium like it's
behind them this week well that that's
why I like that's the for those of you
guys who are watching um so this week so
we Lady Deadpool comes out tomorrow
zombie or I guess zombie Deadpool
Deadpool comes out the next day after
that we do Deadpool kills Deadpool and
then we start into it so it's it's gonna
be pandemonium once once everything
kicks off like it's it's gonna be nuts
but um but anyway so yeah so with that
being said I mean I guess we can go
ahead and call it a day
so all right we'll catch you guys later
yes